all right sup guys mkbhd here and
welcome to dope tech of CES 2018 part
two so if you missed part one I'll link
it up here in the corner that's
clickable in case we got missed in the
flood that is your so box right now but
I did go back to show floor with your
suggestions from Twitter and reddit to
find the things mostly I guess the more
newsworthy things of CES that people
wanted to know more about so right off
the bat actually there were a couple of
things that I wanted to see that I
couldn't so synaptics for example they
were demoing a fingerprint reader
underneath the display glass I'll link
this video that I'm watching below but I
think this is actually gonna have some
pretty sweet implications in smartphones
as early as this year so I'm looking
forward to that but I didn't get to see
it in person myself or try it out I hope
I do soon though and I also wanted to
see but they weren't showing it in their
booth
LG's rollable TV probably the most hype
thing of all of CES I'd say this whole
year so they had this rollable OLED TV
basically it looks like a normal TV when
it's out of the box but it has these
motors and it's flexible and it rolls
into this box that they had when it's
not in use so I guess it's really modern
to be able to completely hide your TV
like that but the other use would be
partially rolling it down to make it
this 21 by 9 ultra wide aspect ratio for
watching those videos or movies with no
black bars or even rolling it almost all
the way down for this mega wide UI they
built in that just displays the weather
and stuff so I thought that was really
cool I wish I got to see it in person
but they took it out the booth or
wherever it was pretty quickly
trust me I asked about it but from what
I've heard this may actually come to
market and be a product we can buy
sooner than we think like this year but
for stuff I did see a CES it was kind of
your classics it's it's your cars and
your TVs they could probably name this
the cars and electronics show and nobody
would even bat an eye
most of the dopest TVs I saw were
pushing the envelope with resolution and
size so you know anyone can make a 45
inch OLED TV at this point that's
relatively thin and beautiful but some
of the insane ones at CES were things
like Samsung's 146 inch modular OLED
display Sony had a massive 85 inch 8k
HDR display blast
10,000 nits of peak brightness into our
eyes which was really impressive stuff
like this again is crazy cool to see and
of course we hope it will show up in
much lower prices in real products in
stores in the future and then in the car
department there's always lots of cars
at CES and then at the height of those
it's a lot of what I guess I would say
like the thyroid a future concept Eevee
autonomous type of thing going on like
take Buyten for example brand new
probably the number one most hyped new
electric car at CES and it checked all
those boxes that Faraday future and
others have checked in the past as well
we had that single fully working
prototype in their booth check a massive
potentially distracting that's still
really cool display behind the steering
wheel replacing the traditional
dashboard check they have the lack of
door handles of course check a lack of
side mirrors but with cameras instead
check and of course they want a best of
CES award without announcing a price or
a release date check I mean that's not
to say this isn't a super cool idea this
concept is fun to see this type of stuff
at CES but I would avoid giving these I
guess too much hype like I have in the
past where they're not actually a real
product yet but on the surface they're
awesome and they're everywhere but
basically the important thing to
remember with them is that word concept
that you'll probably see on it somewhere
if you look up the word concept it's
literally just like a physical
representation of an idea so a concept
car is not a real product yet I don't
think we have a price we have a target
price but we don't have a release date
you can't buy it yet so it's more of a
we'll see but what I did see that you
can buy right now and I'll link it below
is the mattias keyboards what they're
doing is basically what we wanted Apple
to do right now you can't buy a Space
Gray Wireless Apple keyboard unless you
also buy an iMac Pro so mattias is
basically making that keyboard that
anyone can buy plus there's some other
colors so I'm pretty pumped about that
and then on top of that they're also
making a wired and wireless backlit
version of that keyboard so the wireless
backlit version is just on or off with
white light only but the wired version
has a literal physical wheel on the back
for changing through whatever colors you
want at any time in my opinion that is
dope tech I also saw this one of a cine
motion controlled arm in an icon booth
so I've seen sort of stuff like this
before but
in person this one was called the Mark
Roberts motion control bolt and the bolt
jr. two different sized robots and I
kind of want one it's essentially a
robot arm that's computer-controlled
that you can program camera moves into
and you can do all kinds of crazy fast
moving super study stuff that human
hands could never do with a camera of
this weight so it was giving me all
kinds of ideas for tech videos but I'll
I'll just leave it at that
Panasonic kept up their tradition of
having a Tesla in their booth which was
probably pretty useful during that power
outage yes there was a power outage at
CES the biggest electronics show in the
world lost power it's got a love aigis
and there are also robots everywhere
robots to clean your house robots to
help you out with stuff robots to dance
for you
robots to keep you company robots to
play Scrabble against and robots to beat
you at ping-pong
or if you're decent to actually help you
get better at ping-pong I got to play
against it it's it's really uncanny
seeing it like toss the ball up and
serve it that was probably the most
human-like part but for real it's using
AI and it's essentially getting better
as I get better I mean I'd say I'm
pretty decent at ping pong I'm not great
but when I had good longer rallies and
started hitting back a little faster the
robot started putting a little more heat
on its returns too so that number it's
projecting on the net while you're
playing is like a sort of a player
rating of how good you are based on how
fast you're hitting back and your spin
and how hard it is but that also means
the robot as it's playing you is gonna
play you at that level too so for the
record I got up to about a 93 out of a
hundred I'm not bragging but I thought
that was pretty sick and then once I
took the lead I had to quit there also
Huawei mate 10 Pro may have overtaken
red hydrogen 1 as the most hyped phone
of 2018 at least from what I saw on my
timeline I think you know what I'm
talking about it's been kind of
everywhere so I think I'll have a little
review slash rant about this phone
coming up if you're interested in that
also the US Postal Service had a booth
at CES where they were showing off mail
innovation mail innovation
me anyway that's pretty much it that was
my CES 2018 obviously it's a huge show
you can't possibly see everything but I
hope these dopes tech videos gave you a
good idea of what it was like to be
there and some of the stuff we saw I had
a lot of fun and I guess the weight is
on now for seeing if the things we saw
there actually come to fruition I mean
I'm sure 75% of the things that were
there won't like the electric cars tough
to say project Linda from Razer I would
almost bet money it'll never actually
happen but we'll see but you know that
rollable TV yet might actually come
sooner than we think so
until then thanks for watching talk to
guys the next one peace
[Music]